you ask a good question about how to  find a good mentor and that shows that  you appreciate the power of a mentor and  so you're on your way  um so  there's a lot of sources of good advice  and mentoring of course if you can find  someone  who cares about you cares and loves  mentoring and has that  relationship so that you can have a  dialogue with them that's fantastic  but you can also go on tick tock or you  can go to other sources in many ways and  you can get the best mentoring around it  doesn't just have to be the people who  are around you it could be anyone  anywhere to get the best possible advice  if you're looking for it you will find  it